bonjour à tous et à toutes
et comme il a su bien le dire je
m'appelle nafissa hamidou jeu super par
mon papa étant enfant pendant nos
vacances mon papa nos amis ni au village
c'est à tillabéri c'est bon vous
connaissez pas à niamey dont il ya que
des peurs là bas ma grand-mère à des le
bétail donc le peuple avec le bétail
c'est normal quand vous le savez il
m'apprenait nourrir ses bétail donc
j'étais enfant pour moi c'était un jeu
c'était un jeu de nourrir le bétail mais
mais je ne savais pas que ça allait être
dans un domaine que j'allais en prendre
voilà après je suis issu d'une famille
de cinq enfants donc moment cinq enfants
deux garçons devront dès hier je suis la
seule fille entend mener une vie très
heureuse azeroth avec maman et mon papa
mais quand même c'était une vie modeste
ce n'était pas la belle vie où tout
freiné les avions pour allé c'était
l'école publique parce qu'ils m'ont
membres pas n'avait pas beaucoup de
moyens dans le cas cité moderne moma
était femme au foyer
un temps on faisait nous tous avec mes
frères c'est l école publique
donc on avait donc j'ai pour moi à de
l'école publique
je voyais mes autres collègues dans des
écoles privées console donc je me dis tu
es celle là elle va gérer réussite dans
sa vie je n'avais pas pour moi l'école
publique c'est nul
donc voilà et en temps
montaut pas il a eu un peu de sous au
lieu de nous mettre dans les écoles
privées la pluie une seconde forme
ok ça c'est bon il pas une autre femme
la polygamie est celui du monde donc la
polygamie étant acceptés au niger il
prend un deuxième enfant
voilà ça c'est la cata c'est là où
l'histoire a commencé a commencé à
bouger ne peut pas oublier qu'ils
avaient des enfants qu'il a des enfants
qui l'a mise k5 informant et nous
oublient mais du hockey ça commence à
aller
ça va donc ils quittent ils nous
quittent nous avons donc avec mon moment
donc pour la seconde femme complètement
on dirait que ça fasse une sorte de
lavage de cerveau il nous a oubliés et
étant la seule fille pour moi ma haine
travaillais pas donc c'est elle qui
s'occupait de nous c'était difficile ni
une activité génératrice de revenus ni
rien donc quitté l'école privée l'école
publique donc comporter à l'école
publique
qu'est ce que le dis chaque fois courage
courage un jour je trouverais ta voix un
jour tu trouveras town hockey après le
collège l'école publique qui continue
avec le stress m'a ac aurait commencé à
vendre de l'eau fraîche vous faire les
classes les besoins et tous parce qu'il
le faut il faut qu'elle puisse aider ses
enfants elle ce qu'elle voulait ce que
moi qui suis la fille de ne pas être
comme elle elle n'a pas réussi dans sa
vie elle voulait pas me voir au fait
être constitués ou bien comme ça c'est
beaucoup au niger donc éviter d'avoir
une vie très facile d'en de me battre
dans ce qu'elle m'a inculqué ces deux il
faut te battre n'afficher que je te dis
il faut te boîte parce que la famille
tout le monde te regarde côté moment
côté papa il n'ya pas des intellectuels
ip non c'est pas des intellectuels voilà
quand je regarde la télé je vois des
gens qui sont baraqué et voilà qu'ils
seront là devant j'ai jamais pensé être
devant vous je voulais vous
savoir c'est un peu surprise
voilà maintenant après ça un jour j'ai
dit pour le moment j'ai fait le privé ça
n'a pas marché a dit ok j'ai dû moi je
dis que je suis déjà découragé je fais
le brevet ça n'a pas marché des gens
tous y compris mon papa est dit de toute
façon ces enfants là c'est pas la peine
s'ils seront des badauds sait maintenant
que j'ai une bonne femme avec qui me
fera des bons enfants ça c'est pas la
peine donc c'était difficile il y avait
le stress et tout mais je me suis dit
non tu vas pas suivre la facilité bats
toi
elle me dit ebi nafissatou c'est ce que
je veux de toi on le prend une deuxième
fois ok je suis le conseil des moments
je reprends deuxième fois ok je vois je
me vois passer un examen ok maintenant
il faut aller au lycée lycée encore j'ai
dit non ça c'est trop loin
enfin le lycée après tout ce galère la
non non non non j'ai personne pour
m'aider j'ai dit il faut que je fasse
quelque chose
maintenant je j'ai été faire faire le
concours pour une école de santé qui
s'appelle une espèce école de santé
publique au niger est fier trois ans
lesage fin donc je suis sage femme de
formation mais on a été content parce
qu'elle veut au moins que sa fille
montrent le bon exemple est abandonné
par ça ne sent pas bon elle veut que je
fasse que je sois dans la famille le
modèle j'ai dit ok tu ne seras jamais
découragé après ça je j'avais fait
travailler pendant deux ans sous contrat
dans des maternités dans des comme on
appelle ça dans des cliniques privées
après j'ai dit non j'économise et je dis
bon il faut que je fasse ma licence j'ai
j'ai abandonné ce parti fait ma licence
en épidémiologie statistiques c'est
aussi la santé c'est bien elle était
fière de moi
après trois ans je travaillais dans
notre hôtel
il ya un cocktail le joystick pendant
deux ans j'occupais le service de
épidémiologie au niveau de l'hôpital
poudrière pendant deux ans et là je me
dis boycott il faut que tu fasses
quelque chose les teams écoute il faut
continuer et du moment il faut que je
continue je ne dois pas m'arrêter là
besoin un jour je regardais la télé je
voyais une femme qui parlait de
l'entrepreneuriat et il était vraiment
dynamique et tous je dis moi j'aimerais
être comme celle là et elle a été primée
j'ai dû me moment est-ce que je peux pas
être comme celle-là oui moi je crois un
peu à ma fille tu doutes tu doutes mais
moi je crois en toi j'ai dit ok il faut
qu'un jour je sois une qu'enfant il faut
que je viens quand tout le monde la
famille qui pensait que j'allais être
poursuivi ou bien j'allais être une
fille de rien que je leur demande que
moi aussi je suis capable vous voyez
voilà on a dit oui tu pourra le faire
après ça j'ai eu la chance j'étais parti
faire ma maman co2 en gestion des
projets de développement qui n'a rien à
voir avec la santé donc j'ai abandonné
la santé après ça j'ai eu à travailler
dans des ong
et ça continue et je me suis dit mais
jusque là j'ai pas trouvé ma voie
il ya quelque chose en moi qui te qui me
dit c'est pas ça je voulais faire
quelque chose ils se disent mais c'est
quelque chose qui est spécial quelque
chose que un jour au moins je le serais
quelque chose un héritage quelque chose
quand je suis vert parce que je serai
plus là qu'on va parler de moi et que je
vais faire quelque chose qui va me
permettre de contribuer dans ma
communauté
donc j'avais commencé à travailler dans
des ong à aider les gens comme moi qui
étais avant comme moi qui n'avais pas
l'aide de leurs parents voilà j'étais
pas découragé je continue je continue
jusqu'à ce que dans le ng il ya les
espagnols qui étaient venus chercher des
gens comme moi qui ont leurs masters où
il ya une licence dont kim ont octroyé
une bourse d'études je n'ai jamais pensé
quitter prendre l'avion c'est pardonné
parce que pour moi je suis toujours nul
donc je ne servir à rien donc pour me
prendre l'avion c'est autre chose aller
étudier dans un pays moins
nafissa hamidou non ça c'est par moi
quoi non je dis non a ajouté souffrir
voyez que je trais suffit ce jeudi pour
écoute et on dit le fait de ne pas il
faut y croire
dans la vie il faut croire à ce que voir
ce que c'est qu'on veut il faut il faut
croire qu'on me disait madame faut
croire en soi
donc ils m'ont donné la bourse d'études
jeu des partis faire encore deuxièmement
sort ça c'est n'a rien à voir parce que
à niamey je suis nigérienne je viens de
niamey jaugeurs du niger l'égalité
l'équité en forme si c'est compliqué
parce que l'islam fait en sorte que la
femme waouh
elle est toujours à la maison donc
indépendante entreprenariale non ça non
jamais une femme montre principe cela
personne ne veut de moi de toute façon
au niger personne ne veut de moi parce
que je suis sûr que je suis beaucoup
plus simple de moi voilà en temps j'ai
eu la chance il était parti faire j'en
ai plaidoyer dans les projets et
programmes de développement
- affichage à un spécialiste anges à wau
autre chose tout ça ça va on le veut
après les années d'études je reviens au
pays je j'ai eu la chance de travailler
d'être recruté par dans un local et
longer locale ça s'appelle plateforme
paysan d'une hygiène
donc j'ai en tant que conseillère en
jarre et plaidoyer non je m'occupais des
jeunes et des femmes à les conseiller
sur l'entrepreneuriat mais tous ceux
dans le domaine agricole
donc ça me passionnait d'être parmi les
éleveurs voyez pas remis et puis ça ça
me semble ça me plaisait d'aider les
jeunes les femmes vous voyez mon
histoire d'avant j'ai pas eu de la
chance du et là bas là il faut y croire
mais
donc en temps il ya les éleveurs avec
qui je travaillais à chaque fois dans
leurs recommandations d'un séminaire
qu'est ce qu'ils disent non au niger
nous avons 80% de la population
nigérienne sont des éleveurs
nous sommes des éleveurs ça c'est
reconnu il ya beaucoup de gens qui
connaissent quilici sylviane psyché tout
le monde collabore pensent les gens qui
connaissent michel savent ce que c'est
donc il ya que le bétail au niger ne
sont pas un pays d'agriculture mais un
pays d'élevage
voilà je me suis dit mais attend il ya
quelque chose ya un problème qui est là
et les temps au niger ils dépensent plus
de 1 milliard pour racheter l'aliment
bétail qui vient de dans d'autres pays
et pas chez nous alors qu'il ya un autre
centre de recherche dans un centre de
recherches là-bas qui s'appelle
inhérents ils ont un travail et avec il
ne s'est passé avec la fao
donc ils ont ils ont trouvé un formule
de deux qu'on peut localement faire de
l'aliment bétail à base de produits
locaux ce qu'on a localement mais
personne ne travaille avec cette formule
le formula mais les gens préfèrent ceux
qui viennent de l'extérieur
bon c'est l'afrique en comprend voilà
voilà
et un jour je me suis dit mais écoutez
il ya ça mais pourquoi personne ne prend
ce formule là pour crier l'entreprise
pour faire quelque chose
personne ne prend ils disent oh non
c'est de la jambe
j'étais par la fenêtre nom de vouvoyer
l'entrepreneuriat au niger s'est un peu
compliquée j'en dis ok ok non je côtoie
mes deux collègues je leur dis bon
écoutez moi j'aimerais faire quelque
chose est ce que ça vous plaise vous ça
vous plaît de vrais gens devant moi pour
créer notre petite entreprise quelque
chose comme ça est d associer 10
mont-saint-jean mathieu malade et puis
c'est vrai le domaine de toute façon des
hommes voulaient forme l'entrepreneuriat
nu et puis l'aliment bétail qui est
folle de hockey les surfeurs ont été ok
mais je viens je vois ma maman je lui ai
expliqué qui tousse et marc toujours je
suis avec toi tout ce que tu fais dans
ta vie moi je suis avec toi et c'est
parti de là c'est parti de là j'ai créé
l'entreprise en 2013
les gens qui disaient que j'étais folle
que j'étais malade a rejeté par la
fenêtre
ils sont mais nike il commençait à me
voir partout dans le monde partout
l'entreprise comment ça c'est aussi
connaître des amis écoutent mais je peux
être qu on a besoin d'associer jean
rigaud
maintenant vous voulez est associée ça
c'est formidable et voilà et on peut pas
acquis qu'ils étaient là bas vous voyez
à la télé on parlait de sa fille oui oui
c'est ma fille
oui c'est mana qui confie que le creux
qu'il a une fille wave ans et c'était
pénible à et je le voyais comme lucio et
moment agi un ça va
vous allez bien et des moments et le
vient la voir revenir a dit non à la db
coûte c'est comme ça la vie il faut su
patienter et maman merci beaucoup merci
parce que si tu n'étais pas envie
j'allais en planter d'autres chemins
un autre chemin qui n'a rien à voir avec
ça donc jeunes que nous sommes du
courage une fois disent que vous êtes
vous décourager merci